um first thing this morning i visited
with the victims who are here
and i had the
opportunity to speak with the 23 year
old
got some information from her i was also
able to speak to the
guatemala the general council of
guatemala to pass on the information
they were able to contact her mother so
that is something to smile about today
and such a sad day
the other side of serving the surviving
victims here at uhs is sadly the amazing
and difficult work that the bexar county
medical examiner staff are tasked to do
which is
who have died
our medical examiner's office has
carried a heavy load over the last few
weeks from the uvalde victims
and now today
we have reached out to neighboring
counties for assistance from their
medical examiner's offices also
as of one o'clock
very sad to report that we the medical
examiners also has 51 bodies
12 women they have potentially id'd 34
of them
i'm not only angry
about what occurred yesterday but my
heart also mourns for the families who
have lost their loved ones
the governor of the great state of texas
has once again politicized this horrific
tragedy by taking to twitter
and placing the blame on others for his
failures while bodies were still being
removed and others being taken to local
hospitals he chose to be heartless and
point the finger
shame on our governor
his words were also a complete
contradiction to state that this tragedy
was due to open border policies
if there was such a policy as open
borders we wouldn't have had over 50
human lives trying to enter this country
the way they did
we wouldn't be mourning the deaths of so
many people who were simply seeking a
better life
i can't imagine
being in another country and waiting to
get a call from a loved one who's been
traveling for weeks or months
to hear if they've arrived at their
destination safely
and then to see the news of this tragedy
here in their county instead
we are not certain of all the countries
where the victims are from
but i have spoken with the walaman
consul general and they are working to
get information from the hospitals for
their citizens
we're also working with the consulates
of mexico honduras and el salvador el
salvador
if you have a family member that you
fear could be one of the victims you can
call the watermelon consulate
at 956-800-7351
well thank you
the inscription
on our statue of liberty
says give me your time
your poor
and your huddle masses yearning to
breathe free
and our nation was built
on the backs of poor immigrants
and made us a great nation today
today
we mourn for those 51 immigrants
who came to us
to breathe that fresh air
but instead found death
in the state of texas
suffering in a van or trailer
from heat exhaustion
it's a terrible way for us to treat
immigrants
the state of texas
has done just about everything wrong
that i can think of
they participate in building a wall
which does nothing to protect our border
they have spent billions of our
taxpayers dollars state taxpayers
dollars
on paying for the texas national guard
at the border
and they throw innocent people those
that just
lost their lives just like them they
throw them in converted prisons down by
the border
we dehumanize them
we make them people think that there's
something less than us and they are not
less than us
instead of spending texas
dollars on a failed body security
program
we should instead be using those funds
to help immigrants
spend those funds to catch the smugglers
and the crooks that live right here in
texas that did what they did today
state should be spending
dollars helping the immigration courts
to help them move those cases along so
they can decide their state here their
status here
and they should be participating with
the mexican border states and providing
funding for them so that they can
provide shelter and food for the
immigrants that are coming through
mexico
and most of all
our state leaders should be supporting
immigration reform
until the congress it acts a
comprehensive immigration reform that's
fair to people it gives the people for
the great opportunity they're looking
for
we're going to continue to see this
horrible horrible policy
instituted by the state of texas and
complemented by the federal government
we mourn for them
i'm so so pleased what university
hospital has done george hernandez and
his team
sutherland springs massacre
uvalde mass shooting of innocent 19
children and
two teachers and now
51 people dying here in bexar county as
they come across the water
a medical examiner as rebecca stated
has received
all the bodies from uvalde and now she's
facing this
tremendous workload
mendes i can't imagine how they go
through that in the job that they do i
also want to thank the bear county
emergency services for being out there
on site and for bear county sheriff
javier salazar for his attention to the
problem we've got out there
so
we should mourn we should not forget
but we should try to correct the
horrible mistakes this state's making in
our nation's making
my name is tom pina i'm an assistant
public information officer so we want to
make sure that we get everybody in so if
you have some questions we want to make
sure that you understand we cannot talk
about anything that has to do with the
investigation the investigation is
handled by the department of homeland
security and we most certainly want to
make sure that they they can talk about
what they need to talk about but if you
have any questions
with respect to the medical examiner's
office or what the county does then that
would be a good time yes sir again one
more time
there are currently 51 bodies
in the custody of the medical examiner
there are
39 of them are men
12 of them are women
children
so that potentially
some of them are
under the age of 18
but we have to ask you to understand
that
what we have in materials there to
try and identify the individuals
cannot be at this time perfectly matched
to the individuals right
so that is what the medical examiner is
trying to do hence uh
my saying these are potentially people
under 18.
but
not i would say in the t in the teenage
age range
not younger
i'm sorry
so the medical examiner
and the medical examiner's office
their job is to determine the cause and
the manner of death
and these investigations and to identify
the victims
these uh this work will
take days if not longer because you may
imagine
there's 51 victims
and
we want to be very diligent in this work
uh and respectfully to them
talking to family members
especially
they're not getting any response from
the consulate and a lot of them think
that their family members are here in
the hospital they speak their native
language and they're only speaking to us
they're desperate they don't know what
to do what are we gonna do with all
these families
well i've been in communication with the
walaman and consulate they've actually
been very gracious
okay
so i'll answer in english since your
question was in english and then i'll go
to spanish
so i've been in contact with the
walman consulate they've been very
gracious i gave out the number you can
let me know if i need to give that out
again they are also working with the
hospitals to get information they are
also limited because of hipaa rules so
they are working with that
estado in communication
um
foreign
foreign
um
um the question is how long do they
think they'll be able to give bodies to
the families to send them back to their
countries
as i try to explain the uh the pride
this process will take time because the
medical examiner wants to be diligent so
right now
we can only estimate
as you may imagine 51 victims so it'll
take at least several days if not longer
than that and then the information of
their findings will have to be given to
the consulates and then the consulates
will take it from there
it is very difficult if not impossible
right now to answer your question i
understand that people are desperate to
know
but at the same time it is more
complicated because these are
potentially citizens from other
countries and the process is more
complex
i don't have any hospital i don't have
any hospital numbers i don't know if
anybody else does
how many kids
we have the information here at uhs
so we just have this local information
not not the other hospitals
us
what
yeah she was just asking about the kind
of care that they're giving i can
obviously speak for uhs because it is
our county hospital and they are getting
excellent care um
the young woman who's 23 year old
that i visited with this morning for
guatemala
i can personally say that her condition
has gotten better she is better she was
able to speak to me
and
the uhs staff is giving excellent
excellent care i would say the teenage
boy
personally we are asking for prayers for
him
so we can only speak about
the patients we have here at uhs we
don't have the information as you can
imagine
they went out critical care to the
hospitals that had the beds
um
and so strack has organized that
and
different hospitals have yeah you can
abstract different hospitals are
privatized and different things and
there's a lot of hipaa laws that we're
trying to protect is there anything
you're asking about
you want to speak to that anything we're
asking state and federal leaders
i mean i can give you my personal
opinion
people need to get registered to vote
and vote for a governor of texas who
cares about people
period that's what i think we need to do
register and vote
i don't know that is something that
federal authorities decide and you would
have to ask them
they're afraid to come forward because
they think they're going to expose their
family members that are undocumented how
can you ensure that they're going to be
protected because some of them are not
looking for them they're afraid to speak
out because of this reason
that's why they need to go through that
yeah so the important part there is uh
as commissioner clay flores said earlier
they need to contact the consulates
their consulate
so that the consulate can then talk to
our medical examiner's office and then
we can relay information
no no no no that is not the case
oh yeah we don't have that information
available if they were by themselves or
not
yeah man the problem is you're asking us
questions that we can't
answer because this is something lies
within federal authority not within the
authority of the county so i'm sorry but
we don't i just don't have that
information
can you rephrase your question please um
let me tell you i don't trust the state
of texas on any of dealing with
immigrants
nationwide the federal government they
are protected
i can't tell you what some state
officials would do they've passed so
many laws
that tried to discriminate against
immigrants we have
millions of immigrants living here
they're undocumented that don't mean
they're here illegal
but they're afraid to speak up not just
because of this issue
so i have no confidence in what the
state of texas might do when they're
putting innocent people
in a uh
a prison
how can we have any confidence that they
would do anything right
but the federal government will
if we don't have any more questions and
that will conclude today's press
conference thank you
[Music]
[Music]
is
she's no longer critical i spoke with
her this morning she's doing a lot
better
we were able i spoke to the
guatemalan general counsel gave
information they were able to contact
him
teenage boy is still critical